white house correspondent peter ducey
starts us off tonight with a lot of news
live from the north lawn good evening
peter
good evening brett the president is now
trying to use leftover
coven relief money to pay people to get
the shot he thinks 100 per person
is enough of an incentive he is also now
offering to reimburse small and
medium-sized businesses for the time
off employees need to get themselves and
their families vaccinated while also
trying to target
the 12 and up crowd with a pop-up clinic
in every school district
4 million federal employees though don't
get as much of a say
if they don't get vaccinated they're
going to lose out on opportunities to
travel and they're going to be isolated
from their vaccinated colleagues
every federal government employee will
be asked to attest
to their vaccination status anyone who
does not attest
or is not vaccinated will be required to
mask no matter where they work indoors
at the white house
masks are required same with the house
of representatives but not on the senate
side so a group of republican lawmakers
protested inches across the imaginary
line separating the two chambers
those lawmakers are protected from
penalties for violating mass
mandates anyway but the house minority
leader kevin mccarthy has a big issue
with a new regulation
that could land people who refuse the
masks in handcuffs
if you are a capitol police officer you
got orders if a vaccinated staffer
comes across in the house side without a
mask you are ordered to arrest them
but not on the senate this is not the
america we know
this is not pelosi's house this is the
people's house
it still hasn't even been a month since
the president wanted to celebrate
independence from the virus and as masks
return i had a chance last hour to ask
him about some of his past
comments about covid
if you are fully vaccinated you no
longer need to wear
a mat and it's no idea you can i haven't
said if you're fully
vaccinated in an area where
[Music]
that getting vaccinated made a gigantic
difference
and what happened was a new variant came
along
they didn't get vaccinated it was spread
more rapidly
and people more people were getting sick
and at the press briefing today i had a
chance to ask officials whether or not
another one of the president's pledges
regarding this subject could be undone
the one that we are not going to go back
to lockdowns in school
closures and the deputy principal press
secretary karine jean-pierre told me
that with regard to future closures they
are going to listen to the scientists
and listen to the cdc
brett peter what's the white house
trying to do about the expiring
eviction moratorium bret it expires on
saturday and the supreme court says that
any
future extension cannot come from the
cdc again they've got to come from
congress so the president is asking the
democratically controlled congress to do
that out of concern for renters who may
still not be working and
the white house does not want these
renters out on the streets as these
delta
variants spread right i mean a lot of
questions about the owners
of those buildings as well peter thank
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else